[Alkış]
Hoş geldiniz Merhaba
muhteşem görünüyorsunuz Kayseri
gerçekten teşekkür ederiz müthiş bir
kalabalık var Ben her zaman kazanıyorum
ve her zaman kazanmanın sırrını Bugün
sizinle paylaşmak istiyorum ama bu
aramızda sır olarak kalmasın Lütfen siz
de başkalarıyla paylaşın ki çoğalsın
henüz 10 yaşındayken satranç oynamaya
başladım ve Satrançta başarılı olmanın
bazı taktiklerini edindim ama zihnimde
şimdi biraz bundan bahsedeceğim
satranç turnuvaları nasıldır bilir
misiniz bilmiyorum kısaca bahsedeyim
turnuvalara gidersin en alttan sıfır
puanla başlarsın Random olarak
rakiplerinle eşleşirsin ve sonra onlarla
oynayıp tepeye doğru çıkarsın
satranç turnuvalarında profesyonelleştim
ve iyi puanlarla
Tepelere çıkmaya başladım bir süre sonra
hep ilk üçte oldum
Ama dediğim gibi hep ilk 3'te maalesef
birincilik beni bulmuyordu birincilik
beni bulmuyordu ve bu birinci
olabilmenin ruhunu içimde yaşayamadığımı
fark ettim hep aynı rakiple karşı
karşıya geliyordum aynı kişiyle Çünkü
belli bir süre sonra
turnuvaları hep aynı kişiler geldiği
için ilk iki de aynı kişiyle yarışmaya
başlıyorsun ama o kişi yeniliyordum bu
yenilgiyi Aslında o satranç tahtasında
değil zihnimde kaybettiğim fark ettim
turnuvadan bir gün önce gece o maçı
yapıyorum rüyalarımda kabuslarımda ve
gece kabusunda kaybediyorum bir gün
sonra da satranç tahtasında gerçekten
yeniliyorum ben ilk birinciliğimi önce
gece o masadaki zihnimde kazandım bir
gün sonra da gittim ve gerçekten maçı
aldım kızı mat ettim ondan sonra geldi
birincilikler
Ben burada fark ettim ki asıl başarı
Senin kendi zihninde kaybettiğin bu
şeylerden kurtulmak ve
devamlı bu zihnindeki şeyleri kazanmaya
başlamak daha sonra yüzme hayatına
başladım çok yönlü bir insan olmak için
başka şeyler denedim yüzmede de şöyledir
yüzücüler yan yana geçer sıralanır hakem
bir işaret verir taek yormak ister Sonra
bir düdük çalar şeklinde ve suya
atlarsın kulvarlarda yarışırsın
inanılmaz bir atmosferdir ben orada
hiçbir zaman rakiplerle yarışmadım O
seyircileri hiç duymadım hep kendimle
yarıştım Aslında ve bu benim için bir
keyifti hiçbir zaman diğer insanları
yenmeye çalışmadım hep birinci olmanın
gücünü değil de orada yarışmanın keyfini
hissetmek istedim Sonra Finish çizgisine
geldiğimde o sudan çıktığımda Eğer
birisi gelip bana bir madalya takarsa
ne ala takmazsa da tecrübe deyip geçtim
ama çok başarılar yakaladım çok
madalyalar aldım Bu sayede
üniversite hayatımda hayvan besleme
bölümü okudum Ege Üniversitesi zooteknik
bölümü mezunuyum hayvan besleme alanında
kendimi çok geliştirdim Ama bu anlamda
2014 yılında ilk girişimim olan kedi ve
köpek maması markaları kedi ve köpek
kıyafetleri markam olan pet Butik 35'i
kurdum burada insanlar pek bana
inanmadılar güvenmediler Çünkü o
zamanlar bir kedinin gelinlik giymesi
bir köpeğin damatlık giymesi biraz komik
kaçtı ama ben güvendim ve hiçbir zaman
insanları takmadım hep bu hayalin
peşinden koştum şimdi bugün Eğer
e-ticaret markan bir marka olduysa ki
oğlu ve Daha sonrasında kedi köpek
mamalarını şu an Türkiye'nin en iyi
Global
zincir Marketlerinin raflarına
sokabildiysen bunun anlaşmasını yaptık
bu hafta Bu sayede oldu inancımla Oldu
mastercad isminde ve mrki isminde kedi
ve köpek maması markalarım var globalde
Avrupa'da dahil olmak üzere birçok yere
ben bu markalarımı ihracata gönderiyorum
Birçok yerde satışlar yapılıyor
ihracatın güçlü kadınları ödülünü aldım
Evet bunların hepsi bana başarılar
sağlıyor ve bazı rakamları getiriyor
bankada birçok hesabında bir şeylere
sebep oluyor Seni başarılı ilan
ediyorlar son olarak kendi zincir
mağazalardaki Tüm bu raflara dizdiğimiz
markalarımdan sonra bir
Pet Shop açtım ve bu pet Shop'ta da
insanların
Konsept bir mağazayla karşılaşması için
elimden gelen her şeyi yaptım İnsanlar
oraya gelip bilgisayarlarında çalışmalar
yapıp yan tarafta klinikte hayvanların
tedavi edebilecek ve bunun yine bir
Franchise şeklinde Tüm Türkiye'de farklı
alanlara yayılmasını sağlayacaktım Ama
tüm bu başarılarının Ardında Ben aslında
bambaşka bir insanım ben başka bir yanım
daha var ve bu benim
şu anda topuklu ayakkabılarla burada
olmama bakmayın Aslında çiftliklerde
sarı Çizmelerimi giyip gezebildiğim
Tarlalarda gezdiğim bambaşka bir dünyam
var Ben bir hayvan besleme uzmanıyım ve
çiftliklerde çiftçilerin hayallerine
umutlarına Işık oluyorum onlarla
birlikte tarlalara tohum ekiyorum bu
tohumların çıkmasına bu tohumların
yeşermesine hepsine şahitlik ediyorum
ben Çiftlikte çok daha rahatım
çiftliklerde hayvanların içindeki Ben
bambaşka bir benim benim başarılı olmamı
sağlayan ve Yüzümün gülmesine sebep olan
şey aslında toprağa yakın olmak toprağa
ayaklarımın basması orada çok daha rahat
hissediyorum ve bunu fark ettiğim Gündem
beri buğday tarlaların içinden ineklerin
içinden hiç çıkmıyorum Bir bezelyenin
tarlaya ekildiği o güneşe şahitlik
ettiğim günden beri kalbim böyle tarım
için atmaya başladı ve bunu hissettirmek
için elimden geleni yapıyorum çünkü genç
nesilin buna daha çok bağlanmasını
istiyorum çiftçilik üretim tarım Bu
ülkenin geleceği Bunu biliyorum ve bunun
için kalbim inanılmaz hızlı çarpıyor
bezelye hasatlarına gittiğimde çiftçinin
o üretimden elde ettiği ürünleri
gördüğüm zaman nasıl motive oluyorum ve
onlar benim soframa geldiğimde onu
gördüğümde ne kadar mutlu oluyorum
tarifi yok bir patates tarlasında çıkan
o hasatın insanın böyle o kokuyu içine
çekmesi müthiş bir has Ben tam olarak
traktörlerin tepesinde çiftliklerin
içinde gezen bildiğiniz sarı çizmeli bir
silelim Ve bundan da gurur duyuyorum
şimdi
Çok teşekkürler
30 yıllık yaşamımda bana iki rakamı çok
şey ifade ediyor
tip insan Hatta iki tip duygu var iyi ya
da kötü Bunu öğrendiğim günden beri
hayatımda Çok şey değişti İyi ile kötüyü
zihnimde yarattığımı iğne ve kötünün
Aslında bizim duygularımız bizim
kalbimizden geçen ve o an düşündüğümüz
şey olduğunu anladığımdan beri hayatımda
Çok şey değişti ve bu bana gerçekten her
şeyi kazandırdı şimdi biraz ortamı
karartacağım beyinlerimizi karartacağım
maalesef birkaç kötü şey söyleyeceğim
karanlık Odalar şiddet gören çocuklar
şiddet gören kadınların çığlıkları
erkeklerin travmatik yaşadığı bazı
şeyler iş kaygıları iflaslar aldatmalar
tüm bunlar insanın hayatında hepimizin
kafasında şu an farklı belki silüetler
canlanıyor farklı Anılar var ama
hepimizde böyle bir Karamsarlık
oluşturuyor Oysa masmavi bir denizin
ortasında şimdi Sizden bir şey istesem
yapar mısınız Bir kaç dakikacık hepiniz
gözlerinizi kapatır mısınız Ve
ellerinize dizilerinizin üstüne koyar
mısınız rahat bir pozisyonda Lütfen ben
de yapacağım Çok az sürecek teşekkürler
şimdi derin bir nefes alalım hem de ben
Heyecanımı da atmış olayım önce alalım
şu nefesi
şimdi verelim
oh Ben de rahatladım teşekkürler
burnumuzdan nefesi alırken yine alacağız
masmavi bir denizin ortasında çıplak
ayaklarınızın denizin o tuzlu suyuna
değdiğini hissedin lütfen isterseniz
Üzerinizde hiçbir şey olmasın Kendinizi
nasıl rahat hissediyorsanız isterseniz
keten bir kıyafet olsun üstünüzde
rüzgar'ı hissedeceğini denizin o
dalgalarını hissedin
sular
ayaklarınıza derken o muhteşem kum
taneleri parmak uçlarınıza değiyormuş
gibi düşünün
Şimdi herkesin yüzünde güzel bir
gülümseme var biliyor musunuz
gözlerinizi açabilirsiniz Çok
teşekkürler insan kötü bir şey
düşündüğünde bir anda surat ifadesi
değişiyor ve iyi bir şey düşündüğü zaman
Aslında iyi hissediyor Eğer kendimizi
dış ortama değil de kendimize odaklayıp
bu dış dünyadan uzak tutup sadece
duygularımızı doğruyu yönetebilirsek
gerçek mutluluğu yakalayabiliriz
Bir insan
ortalama günde 2617 defa o cebimizdeki
telefonu dokunuyormuş
kimler geceleri telefonunu şarja takıyor
Mesela ben
salonun neredeyse hepsi telefonunu gece
şarja takıyor biliyor musunuz %90'ı
Ben aslında telefonumu değil Sadece gece
bir şey daha şarja takıyorum kendimi
her sabaha yeni bir uyanışla dünü
tamamen geride bırakarak uyanıyorum ve
bu beni inanılmaz enerjik inanılmaz
pozitif tutuyor Eğer bir gün önce
yaşadığınız geçmişi geride
bırakabilirseniz hayatınız çok değişiyor
Lütfen bunu Yarından itibaren uygulamaya
başlayın geçmişi değiştiremiyoruz
arkadaşlar ama geleceğe müdahale
edebiliyoruz Ben az önce bu kumandayı
hareket ettiremiyordum Ama şu saniyeden
sonra ettirebiliyorum bu saatten sonra
aldım seyirciyi bundan sonra önemli
benim için geçmiş önemli değil değişmez
ve bu dış koşullara bağlı mutluluğu
bırakıp kendi içimizdeki zihnimizdeki O
gerçek gücü yakaladığımız anda yüzler
gülmeye başlıyor Aslında
Bazı insanların hayatında bazı şeyler
yolunda gitmiyor Şimdi size bir şey
göstereceğim
şöyle yapalım
Birkaç saniye
[Müzik]
elimde iki tane çakmak var İkisi de
birbirinden farklı renkte ikisi farklı
insanları temsil ediyor ama aslında
İkisi de doğduklarında hayata
geldiklerinde bir kıvılcıma sahipler
İkisi de yanıyor
ama bazen bazı insanların hayatında bazı
şeyler çok ters gidiyor bakalım
[Müzik]
Bazı insanlar şiddet görüyor
Bazı insanlar aldatılıyor Bazı insanlar
sevgisiz büyüyor Bazı insanlar zulme
vuruyor dışlanıyorlar ve bunların hepsi
bu insan hayatında bir
bir alıyor kaybediyor götürüyor
hayatından
bu insan hayatındaki
en değerli şey
şimdi gitti
artık onun bir kıvılcımı yok
Işık saçamıyor etrafa
Onun da az da olsa tekrar kıvılcım
vermeye başladığını
Evet yavaşça tekrar aydınlık saçacağını
ve etrafa tekrar Işık saçabileceğini
Göreceksiniz sadece bir şans verin
gördüğünüz gibi eğer bir insana bir şans
verirseniz yine siz kazanıyorsunuz onu
topluma kazandırmış oluyorsunuz Ben bunu
yapmaya çalışıyorum insanlara enerji
Işık yaymaya çalışıyorum Çok teşekkür
ederim
[Alkış]